these cars are waiting for something
that is usually
cheap and easy to get in the middle east
fuel
this crisis is now so bad that some
people spend
all night in their vehicles just so they
can be at the front of the queue in the
morning
as people try to fill up before the fuel
runs out or the power goes off
i'm a surgeon i'm a doctor and i have to
wait for hours and hours
and i have to go to the hospital right
now and i can't my car is empty
i mean this is chaos and
every petrol station that is open and a
lot of them are closed
is like this and you know what it's not
just people with low
incomes there are cars in here we've
seen lexuses
porsches range rovers it's affecting
everybody in lebanese society the queue
stretches all the way down there and
this
is beirut the capital things are better
here
if you get elsewhere in the country it's
a lot worse
[Music]
to see that for ourselves we left beirut
and went to tripoli in the north
lebanon's second largest city aunt
layla runs a small charity to get food
and medicine to people
and takes us to see some of the families
she helps
majido shows me her fridge besides the
medicine in the door
there is little food on the shelves
water some water and
really i mean there's not a lot for a
family of
seven or eight of you aren't there this
is what you have
no meat though meat is an unaffordable
luxury
for many people now her son lies
sprawled asleep on the family bed
the ceiling above him is crumbling and
falling down he works nights down at the
port
a shift will earn him two dollars that
doesn't buy a lot
we're given permission to enter one of
tripoli's poorest and most dangerous
districts
almost everyone who lives here lives
below the poverty line
the nasa family's small flat is on the
first floor
walid is barely conscious when we see
him his family are worried that his
cancer has returned
and he is now struggling to breathe he
relies on an oxygen machine
and the love of his wife
as the sun sets beirut falls into
darkness
state provided electricity is in short
supply even though people are still
paying their taxes
to a dysfunctional government that isn't
delivering
the man tasked with forming a new
government has now stepped down
side hariri's decision to walk away from
his role
has pushed this crisis even deeper
nobody knows what will happen next
revolutions start when people are
desperate
and have no other option the fires of
protests
are burning in the streets of lebanon
again
and there is no one to put them out
aleister bunkel sky news
lebanon